Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özgüval. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmengespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten und dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich habe der Sekretärin meine Daten gegeben. Warum fragen Sie mich noch mal?
Das ist für uns sehr wichtig, um gleiche Namen mit anderen Patienten nicht zu verwechseln. Das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Ok, danke.
Um sehr wohl zu gehen.
Ok, na klar. Ich heiße Philipp Kea, Herr Doktor.
Philipp Kea. Können Sie bitte den Vornamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ok, Herr Doktor. Mein Vornamen buchstabiert sich P wie Paula, H wie Heinrich, I wie Ida, L wie Ludwig, I wie Ida und am Ende Doppel P wie Paula.
Und mein Nachname ist K wie Kaufmann, E wie Emil, Y wie Emil und am Ende R wie Richard.
Bei dem Vornamen nur eine L.
Nur Doppel P.
Und Doppel P. Vielen Dank. Alles gut. Herr Kea, wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
59 Jahre alt. Alles gut. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin am 11.11.1965 geboren.
65 geboren. Das passt. Herr Kea, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Oh, bitte beeilen Sie sich, Herr Doktor. Ich habe Angst. Ich habe Muschimärzen.
Ich bin 1,90 Meter. Entschuldigung, Sie haben die Gewichtskragen.
Alles gut.
Ich wiege 90 Kilogramm und ich bin 1,90 Meter groß. Entschuldigung. Alles gut.
Ich bin ein bisschen verriet wegen meiner Schmerzen.
Alles gut. Herr Kea, was für Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wie gesagt habe ich Brustschmerzen, Herr Doktor. Obwohl Sie jetzt ein bisschen besser sind, habe ich seit zwei Stunden Brustschmerzen.
Seit zwei Stunden?
Ja, seit ungefähr zwei Stunden habe ich plötzlich so einen dumpfen, drückenden Schmerzen hier hinter dem Brustbein, Herr Doktor.
Seit zwei Stunden ein stehendes, brennendes Schmerz.
Nein, ein dumpfen und drückendes Schmerz.
Dumpfen und drückenden Schmerzen.
Vorher haben Sie einhebende Schmerzen?
Ja, vorher habe ich aber jetzt schwer und früher war es leichter als jetzige Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
In den letzten drei Monaten hatte ich schon ab und zu so ähnliche Beschwerden, aber wie gesagt waren sie viel leichter als jetzige.
Und ich würde gerne wissen ob die Schmerzen und Beschwerden einigermaßen aushalten können oder?
Was bitte?
Halten Sie aus die Schmerzen?
Das ist besser, aber es macht mir Angst.
Ich verstehe. Ich zähle die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Eigentlich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Eigentlich nicht.
Der Schmerz bleibt eher...
Vielleicht müssen Sie ihn in den Halsbereich...
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Der Schmerz bleibt eher in der Mitte der Brust, also direkt hinter dem Brustbein.
Vor der Brustbein oder hinter dem Brustbein? Wie beschreiben Sie das?
Hinter dem Brustbein.
Hinter dem Brustbein. Seit zwei Stunden.
Ungefähr.
Alles gut. Also nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie aktuell ein Medikament angenommen?
Herr Doktor, habe ich vielleicht Herzinfarkt oder Herzschlag?
Ja, kann ich nicht genau sagen. Ein paar Fragen stellen würde ich.
Wie beschreiben Sie, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Kein Schmerzen, wobei Sie sehr stark sind?
Am Anfang würde ich sagen, bei sechs von zehn. Im Moment ist es etwas besser.
Vielleicht drei bis vier. Aber ganz weg ist es eben nicht.
Alles gut. Und dagegen haben Sie kein Medikament eingefahren?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Direkt ins Krankenhaus.
Ich bin nicht gefahren.
Nein, Herr Doktor. Direkt ins Krankenhaus bin ich gefahren.
Ich verstehe Sie. Alles gut.
Herr Kehr, jetzt gibt es einen Notfallverdacht.
Ich muss diese Gespräche sofort beenden.
Ich werde Sie auf jeden Fall stationär aufnehmen und sofort einen EKG durchführen.
Dann ein paar Politische Laboren untersuchen.
Wenn alles gut geht, können wir weiterfahren. Alles gut?
Okay, Herr Doktor. Das hat mich ein bisschen beruhigt.
Ich werde Sie aufnehmen. Erst einmal ein großlämiger, lumiger Zugang legen und dann ein Elektrocardiogramm durchführen.
Okay, danke Herr Doktor.
Herr Kehr, wie geht es Ihnen?
Jetzt besser. Ich habe auch Schmerzen, aber ich fühle mich ein bisschen sicher.
Wie ist Ihre Brustschmerzen? Wie ist Ihre Brustschmerzen momentan?
Wie gesagt, Sie sind auch da, aber ich fühle mich sicher als Vorhaber.
Alles gut. Und können wir weiterführen?
Ja, bitte Herr Doktor.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass die Schmerzintensität am Anfang 6 und dann in Ruhe ist und jetzt 3 und 4.
Ja Herr Doktor.
Alles gut. Und Herr Winter, gibt es noch andere Beschwerden?
Vielleicht haben Sie noch andere Begleitsymptomen?
Ich weiss nicht, was die Begleitsymptomen sind, aber ich kann sagen...
Sie haben ein bisschen Katschweiß, Schweißausbruch.
Okay Herr Doktor. Ich hatte plötzlich schlechte Luft.
Also ein Gefühl von Atemnot. Mir war auch etwas übel währenddessen.
Aber ich musste nicht erbrechen Herr Doktor. Nur Übelkeit hatte ich.
Seit wann dauert diese Übelkeit?
Ich meine...
Heute Morgen?
Heute Morgen, seit 2 Stunden meine ich.
Aber keine Erbrechen? Und haben Sie Dyspno?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte ziemlich schlechte Luft. Vielleicht Atemnot.
Haben Sie Katschweiß?
Ja, und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich kalt geschwitzt habe und mich irgendwie total schlecht gefühlt habe Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe. Nur heute Morgen oder?
Ja, ich meine seit heute Morgen.
Alles gut. Haben Sie Vertigo?
Was ist Vertigo Herr Doktor?
Haben Sie Schwinden?
Nein, ich hatte nicht Schwinden. Nur Atemnot und Übelkeit und diese Katschweiß.
Müdigkeit, Fatigue?
Ja, ich fühle mich natürlich müde, aber nicht so erschöpft.
Alles gut. Sind Sie ein Hapartit und Durst?
Seit einer Stunde habe ich nichts gegessen, aber früher war es normal.
Haben Sie heute schon gefrühstückt oder etwas gegessen?
Heute Morgen habe ich gefrühstückt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist immer stabil Herr Doktor.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt. Vielleicht messen Sie es in körperlicher Untersuchung oder hier?
Ja natürlich. Aber am Anfang, ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten bemerkt? Zum Beispiel am Bein oder im Waden?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, gestern Nacht habe ich es bemerkt, aber ich habe keine Probleme mit Schlafen.
Haben Sie Angst?
Natürlich Herr Doktor, ich habe viel Angst.
Was für eine Angst?
Ich habe Angst vor Tod.
Ich verstehe. Alles gut.
Haben Sie noch eine andere chronische dauerhaftige Erkrankung? Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Vagakrankheit oder Bronchitis?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit etwa 15 Jahren Bluthochdruck.
15 Jahre Bluthochdruck.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es gut kontrolliert ist. Ich messe nicht regelmäßig, nur in der Praxis kontrolliert.
Nur in der Praxis. Alles gut.
Außerdem habe ich seit ungefähr zehn Jahren erhöhte Cholesterinwerte, Herr Doktor.
Und Cholesterinwerte?
Und ich habe schon länger eine chronische Hüste.
Chronische Hüste? Seit wann haben Sie eine chronische Hüste?
Seit Jahren, vielleicht 20 Jahren, weiß ich nicht.
Seit 20 Jahren?
Ja, mindestens 20 Jahre, aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Alles gut. Und die Hüste mit Auswurf oder? Haben Sie Auswurf?
Meistens trocken, aber manchmal habe ich auch Spürtum. Aber meistens trocken.
Herr Kehr, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Herr Doktor, als ich zwölf Jahre alt war, hatte ich eine Operation.
Was für eine Operation? Was meinen Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich weiß nicht genau, aber während des Ressort Spielen hatte ich einen Unfall und eine Beinfraktur.
Wegen dieser Fraktur wurde bei mir eine Operation durchgeführt.
Operation durchgeführt.
Gab es eine Beinfraktur?
Ja, wie gesagt.
Beinfrussspieler. Rechte oder linke Fuß?
Rechte. Rechte Beine.
Das war komplikationlos oder?
Das war normal. Alle verlaufen komplikationlos.
Alle sind.
Herr Kehr, haben Sie eine Allergie gegen etwas?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Atmosallergie. Wenn ich Atmos esse, bekomme ich Atemnot und Schwellungen in den Mund. Deshalb passe ich da sehr auf.
Mundschwellungen. Und leicht Yukreas.
Hortausschlag. Nur Schwellungen. Mundschwellungen.
Und auch Atemnot, wie gesagt.
Und Atemnot.
Ernsthaft ist Atemnot für mich, wenn ich Atemnot esse.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe nicht Atemnot gehört.
Ich habe nur Mundschwellungen gehört. Nehmen Sie die regelmäßige Medikamentale?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich nehme Ramiplil 5 mg morgens und Simvastatin 40 mg abends. Einmal pro Tag. Und sonst eigentlich nichts regelmäßiges.
Ramiplil wie viel mg?
5 mg morgens.
40 mg abends.
Warum nehme ich Simvastatin abends, aber Ramiplil morgens?
Simvatate ist ein Gegenkollesterin Medikament.
Ja?
Ja, also Sie haben eine hohe Brutfertigkeit glaube ich. Und Ihrem Arzt hat Ihnen ein Simvastatin geschrieben.
Ok.
Und dann Herr Kair. Herr Kair, rauchen Sie?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich rauche ungefähr 3 Zigaretten am Tag.
3 Zigaretten? Seit wann?
Seit etwa 30 Jahren.
30 Jahren, täglich nur 3 Zigaretten.
3 Zigaretten.
Nicht so schlimm glaube ich. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Aber der Arzt hat mir gesagt, das ist auch schlimm, weil ich so lange geratet habe.
Ja natürlich. 30 Jahre.
Aber auch wenn die Zahlen wenig sind, soll man kurze Zeit rauchen. Aber nicht so rauchen.
Ja, ich verstehe natürlich, das ist nicht so gut. Aber als Allgemeingesellschaft täglich 30 Zigaretten ist sehr gut.
Normalerweise rauchen viele Jüngere täglich 1 Schachtel.
Ok, ich mache weiter zu rauchen Herr Doktor.
Nein, versuchen Sie es mal mit dem Rauchen auf sich.
Das war jetzt ja.
Ja, wir bitten für Sie eine Unterstützung.
Ja, weil mein Brustschmerzen ist weg, mache ich Witz Herr Doktor.
Ja, nach dem Gespräch können wir wieder sprechen über diesen Thema. Eine Unterstützung mit dem Rauchen aufzuholen.
Danke Herr Doktor.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke ich eher wenig Herr Doktor. Vielleicht ein bis zwei Mal pro Woche. Ein Glas Wein.
Ein Glas Wein.
Ja.
Herr Kehr, mitnehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine ganz ganz ganz Routinefrage.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert?
Nein Herr Doktor, ich habe nie probiert.
Herr Kehr?
Aber Herr Doktor, vielleicht viele Schülerinnen nutzen solche Drogen oder zum Beispiel Mittelsurzeit?
Ja, es tut mir leid. Es tut mir leid, dass es so viel Suizid, Sie haben recht. Das ist ein großes Problem für uns, für alle.
Und wir sollen dagegen etwas machen.
Ja, ich bin Mathelehrer und beobachte das jeden Tag Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Kinder Herr Kehr?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe eine Tochter.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie Angst haben. Wie viel ist Ihre Tochter?
Ja, Jura ist die Name meiner Tochter. Sie ist 25 Jahre alt und studiert auch. Entschuldigung, Jura. Sie studiert Jura.
Bei der Jura studiert sie.
Julia studiert Jura.
Ok, ich verstehe Sie, dass Sie Angst haben. Sie haben ganz ganz ganz recht.
Nein, nein. Jetzt bin ich sehr beunruhigt Herr Doktor.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch Herr Kehr?
Ja Herr Doktor, aber mein Vater, Entschuldigung, vor zwei Jahren ist mein Vater an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Beide sind verstorben Herr Doktor. Meine Mutter ist auch verstorben. Sie hatte vor drei Jahren einen Schlaganfall und...
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Daran ist sie verstorben. Sie hatte auch Bluthochdruck Herr Doktor. Ist der Bluthochdruck erblich?
Als theoretisch kann es sein, aber nicht ganz. Ja, das ist natürlich sehr wichtig.
Der Lebensstil, Ernährungsstil und Bewegung zum Beispiel Sport treiben ist sehr wichtig. Rauchen ist sehr wichtig.
Nicht nur verantwortlich, erblich.
Ok Herr Doktor. Alles klar.
Herr Kehr, was machen Sie beruflich?
Wie gesagt bin ich Mathelehrer.
Mathelehrer. Ich habe vergessen, Sie sind Mathelehrer. Sie sind verheiratet oder?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Sie haben eine Tochter Julia bei der Jura. 25 Jahre alt. Alles gut Herr Bayer.
Ich möchte nur die letzte Frage stellen. Wie lange dauert Ihre Atake? Brustschmerzen. Ich meine Brustschmerzen.
Wie gesagt, in den letzten drei Monaten hatte ich schon ab und zu ähnliche Beschwerden.
Ich habe nicht als Ataken beobachtet. Weiß ich nicht. Aber es war viel leichter als heute.
Ja, alles gut. Aber Herr Doktor, Sie möchten wissen, die Schmerzen kamen meistens bei Belastung.
Ja, natürlich.
Zum Beispiel beim Treppensteigen. Sie haben vielleicht 10 Minuten gefragt. Aber jetzt kann ich sagen, vielleicht 10 Minuten.
Vielen Dank für die Frage.
Es hat gedauert. Deshalb habe ich mir damals nicht so viele Gedanken gemacht, weil es nicht so stark war. Aber heute bin ich ...
Zum Beispiel, wie viele Treppen können Sie hochgehen, ohne Pause?
Damals, ich habe nie gerechnet. Aber ...
Vielleicht 2. Etage, 3. Etage?
Ja, ich wohne im 2. Etage.
Ohne Pause.
Ohne Pause konnte ich früher steigen. Aber seit den letzten drei Monaten muss ich eine Pause machen.
Wie viele Kilo tragen Sie?
Ich habe nicht gerechnet.
Ich habe nie gerechnet, Herr Doktor. Ich weiß nicht.
Alles gut. Herr Kehr, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig. Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Aber natürlich. Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe und ob ich hier bleiben soll oder muss.
Oder ob ich operiert werden soll.
Das kann ich momentan nicht genau sagen. Wir sollen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen, Herr Kehr. Aber sollen Sie aktuell hier bleiben?
Wenn alles gut läuft, können Sie gerne nach Hause gehen. Aber erst einmal sollen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Bitte seien Sie ein bisschen geduldig.
Wegen Angst habe ich viele Fragen im Kopf. Danke für Ihr Verständnis und für die Geduld, Herr Doktor. Danke.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Ich warte auf Sie, Herr Doktor.
Herr Kehr, Sie warten hier. In 30 Minuten können Sie sich in die Wasserpapier schütteln und dann können Sie weiter gehen. Alles gut.
Vielen Dank. Es war kein typischer Fall, aber es hat mich nachher sehr entspannt.
Ich bin sehr glücklich.
Ich habe mich nicht so gut getrocknet.
Ich finde es sehr gut.
Herr Kettin, Sie waren sehr gut.
Herr Doktor, es ist normalerweise sehr schlecht. Der Mann in Lumbar zieht mich sogar sehr gut.
Er hat sich sehr gut in die Reaktion verabschiedet. Er ist ein guter Typ.
Aber es gibt extra Reaktionen, Herr Ekrem.
Herr Ekrem, du antwortest sehr gut. Was ist das für ein Instinkt?
Calm down. Wir beten, dass wir inshallah durchgehen werden.
Vielen Dank.
Herzlichen Dank.
Herr Ekrem, möchte ich direkt beginnen?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten bei der Notaufnahme aufgenommen und ihm die Äffektionsweise vorgestellt.
Sehr schön.
Es geht um Philipp Schaeher. Er ist 59 Jahre alt und wurde am 11. November 1965 geboren.
Er wiegt 19 Kilo und ist 1,90 Meter groß.
Heute Morgen kam er zu uns und hat seit zwei Stunden plötzlich aufgetreten, stechen, brennen und dumpfen.
Er hatte eine retrosyterne Brustschmerzen.
Er hat die Schmerzen vor zwei Stunden begonnen und am Anfang die Schmerzkarte stechen, brennen und dursieren.
Aber jetzt er bildet sich ausdrückend.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus. Das ist eine interessante Weise.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei Belastung 6 von 10. In Ruhe 3 bis 4 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Entschuldigung, die Schmerzintensität liegt bei Belastung 6 von 10 oder in Ruhe 4 von 10. Am Anfang liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 6 von 10 und momentan 4 von 10.
Am Anfang liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 6 von 10, aber jetzt 4 von 10.
Die Schmerzen bei Belastung oder in Ruhe aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen in Ruhe aufgetreten. Heute Morgen nach dem Frühstück.
Die Patientin sagt, dass er eine Schmerzbeschwerde seit ein paar Monaten hatte.
Insbesondere beim Treppensteigen.
Wie lange dauert die Attacke? Die Patientin weiß nicht. Keine Weise.
Die Patientin sagt, seit zwei Stunden hat die Patient Schmerzen.
Seit zwei Stunden die Schmerzen begonnen.
Diese Attacke dauert seit zwei Stunden.
Aber vorher gibt es noch ähnliche Attacke oder Beschwerden.
Die Patientin sagt, es gibt aber keine feste Zeit.
Am Ende habe ich gehört, dass er ungefähr zehn Minuten gesagt hat.
Aber am Anfang haben Sie recht, er hat nichts daran erinnert.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Begleitend sind ein Gynaphektorist, Neuse, Dyspno, Kaltschweiß und Fetig.
Die Vegetative-Anamnestischen ergeben sich in Appetanz und Schlafsturm wegen Todangst.
Als Vorerkrankung leidet er seit 15 Jahren an arterialen Hypatonie und Hyperkolesthymemie.
Er klagt über eine seit solange dauernde chronische Hüste.
Ab und zu mit Sputum oder Auswurf.
Mit Kamantös nimmt er regelmäßig 5 mg Ramiplil täglich morgens.
Er hat gegen Erdnuss eine Allergie, reagiert auf Mundschwellung und Atemnot.
Zu den Noxen der Patientrauch seit 30 Jahren täglich 30 Rätten.
Bei der Alkoholkonsum wurde er ein Glas Wein pro Woche beantragt.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Bei der Familienanamnese berichtet er der Vater, dass er mit der Drogenkonsum in die Nase geraten ist.
Bei der Familienanamnese berichtet er, dass der Vater an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben ist.
Die Mutter ist an einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt mit der Familie zusammen.
Er hat eine Tochter, 25 Jahre alt, studiert Jura und ist gesund.
Er ist Mathelehrer.
Bei der Alkoholkonsum wurde er auf eine akute Koronazentrome verdacht.
Wer hat den Patienten mit der akuten Koronazentrome?
Plötzlich ist er aufgetreten und hat eine Brustmärze.
Wer hat den Patienten mit der Akute Koronazentrome verdacht?
Er hat seit 30 Jahren Rauchen.
Wie viele Zigaretten hat er täglich?
Täglich 3 Zigaretten würde er verdanken.
3 Zigaretten?
Ja, 3 Zigaretten.
Das kommt mir auch interessant.
Aber jede Zigarettenmenge schädlich unseren Körper?
Ja, das stimmt.
Er leidet an Arteriellhypertonie seit 5-10 Jahren.
Er leidet an Hypercholesturnemie.
Er trinkt Alkohol.
Er ist 90 Kilo.
Ein bisschen adipositiv.
Aber wie groß ist er?
1,90 Meter groß.
1,90 Meter? Und er wiegt 90 kg.
Dann? Das bedeutet?
Ich rechne.
Ich glaube, dass er nicht adipositiv ist.
Ja, bei dem Index 22.
Er ist nicht adipositiv.
Ich dachte nur Kilo.
Wenn ich 90 Kilo bin, dann kannst du sagen, du bist adipositiv.
Aber ein Mann ist 1,90 Meter groß.
Wenn wir Risikofaktoren nennen, achten wir neben Feuerkrankungen und Alkoholkonsum auf die Familienanamnese.
Es gibt wichtige Informationen in der Familienanamnese.
Ich habe noch vergessen, Lebensstil, Fragen stellen, vielleicht Sport treiben oder Arbeit belastung.
Diese Fragen habe ich leider vergessen.
In der Familienanamnese gibt es wichtige Informationen.
Der Vater ist verstorben durch Herzinfarkt.
Das ist eine genetische Belastung.
Die Mutter leidet an Schlaganfall.
Schlaganfall auf eine Gefäßeprobleme.
Ja, Mathe, Skoda.
Okay.
Man kann beide sagen. Schlaganfall und Herzinfarkt.
Welchen Differentialdiagnosen kommen in Betracht?
Als Differentialdiagnostik kommen eine Gastroesophagealreflukkrankheit und eine Artkoaktation.
Was bedeutet Artkoaktation?
Eine Artkoaktation.
Ein Quartier.
Eine Quartier ist zu viel zu sagen.
Sie haben eine Artkoaktation.
In einer Kopie EC2-Floid hat es keine Differentialdiagnose, es ist nicht immer festgehalten.
Also, sie können schlaue Differentialdiagnose und eine Artkoaktation.
Sie haben schon während des Gesprächs eine Frage geschrieben und die Pulmonarenembolie ausgeschlossen.
Ist Ihnen abgefahren, dass Sie geschwollen werden?
Meine Differential Diagnost ist eine esophagische Reflungkrankheit und eine Lungenembolie.
Okay.
So weiter in Abklärung. Was würden Sie durchführen?
Als erstes würde ich eine Köpfe schieben und durchführen.
Blutbild und Badeblutbild, Nehren und Leber werden insgesamt gewertet.
Und Herzensin, Töponin und Kratinkneas MB und Genomparametall.
Aber Sie haben schon etwas Blut abgenommen?
Ja, haben wir schon.
Und eine EKG verschreiben.
Gegebenfalls eine Eschokardiographie und einen Kardiologischen Konsil anfordern.
Und was noch?
Bei dieser Erklärung können Sie sagen, ich habe schon eine Unterbrechung gemacht.
Und während des Gesprächs habe ich schon Blut abgenommen, eine EKG geschrieben und die Vitalparameter überprüft.
Hier sagen Sie diese Information.
Ich empfehle Ihnen.
Sollen wir das simulieren? Vielleicht Töponin ein bisschen hochstiftet.
Nein, nein. Du solltest keine Ergebnisse geben.
Du solltest nur nennen, was Sie gemacht haben.
Ja, ich verstehe. Alles gut.
Bei der Anamnesigesprache habe ich das Aufnahmegespräch untergebracht.
Und habe sofort eine EKG durchgeführt und Blut abgenommen.
Bei der Anamnesigesprache habe ich eine Nierenwerte, eine Leberwerte, eine Differentialblutbildung und Herz-Enzyme-Kardia.
Warum eine Differentialblutbildung?
Das ist eine Routine.
Nein, eine Blutbildung ist eine Routine.
Ja, eine Blutbildung.
Und Töponin und T und Kratenkenas, MB und Genoparameter, auch sehr wichtig.
Gernungsparameter.
Gernungsparameter. Muss ich das erklären?
PTT.
Nein, das ist eine Diagnose.
Die Diagnose ist sehr wichtig.
Dann wurde eine EKG durchgeführt und noch eine Kardiolikschekkonzil angefordert.
Nach dem Ergebnis, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das hier erklären kann,
Aber ich kann es nicht sagen, dass ich mich immer wieder gut fühle.
Das ist nicht nötig. Du kannst es jetzt normalerweise bei Ekrem sagen.
Ich verstehe.
Aber was ist das?
Apparativ.
Was haben wir in der Zeit?
Ich meine immer, dass man Apparativ ist.
Apparativ bedeutet, dass man Blut hat,
die Körperwerte unterzuchen, die Vita-Klimatisierung kontrollieren, die EKGs machen.
Die ganzen zusätzlichen Tätigkeiten, die man weiter machen wird, apparativ sind.
Zum Beispiel wie bei diesem Patienten Eko,
bei einem anderen Patienten CT-Tätigkeiten,
bei einem anderen Patienten ein anderes Ultraschall.
Das sind Apparativ-Mitglieder.
Ich verstehe.
Apparativ bedeutet, dass ich eine EKG, eine Eko-Kardiographie veranleite.
Kann eine Eko-Kardiographie in einer Apparativ-Tätigung gehen?
Ich denke, dass es bei jemandem mit M-Kontrollen nicht möglich ist.
Hier ist alles möglich, aber du musst es sagen.
Apparativ bedeutet nicht, dass man es zusätzlich macht.
Apparativ bedeutet, dass man die entsprechenden Methoden hat.
Du musst es sagen.
Was zusätzliches?
Ich denke, dass Apparativ immer zusätzlich ist.
Apparativ-Diagnostik, Eko-Kardiographie,
eine Röntgen-Thorax, gegen Muslans eine CT-Angioterapie
bei Bedarf an coronare Angioterapie.
Das würde ich empfehlen.
Für diesen Fall.
Wie würden Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Wenn mein Verdacht-Diagnost bestätigt ist,
auf jeden Fall würde ich diese Patientstation aufnehmen.
Welche Station?
Intensivstation.
Auf jeden Fall zum Intensivstation aufnehmen sollen.
Mit Montageüberwachung.
Derp nach dem Morphin.
Sauerstoffgabe.
Gegeneinander Nitroglycerin.
Auf jeden Fall ASS.
Heparin und Klopidogel.
Mono-B-Chemik.
Und Betablocker?
Gibt es noch Betablocker?
Habe ich nicht noch jetzt?
Wenn der Patient eine Stand bekommt,
dann geben wir eine Klopidogel.
Zweite Thrombocytin-Aggregation.
Aber am Anfang geben wir nicht Klopidogel.
Mono-B-H-Chemik.
Morphin.
Mono-B-H.
Klopidogel keine am Anfang.
Klopidogel, Citatin.
Normalerweise Betablocker.
Oder ASE.
Hema.
Oder Angiotensin-Rezeptor.
Antagonisten.
Wird als sekundäre Therapie empfohlen.
Aber Mono-B-H.
Mono-B-H.
Hema.
Geben wir im Notfall.
Morphin.
Oxygen.
Ja, Morphin, Oxygen, Nitroglycerin.
ASS, Heparin.
ASS und Heparin.
Mono-B-H-B, Betablocker.
Mono-B-H.
Betablocker.
Ok, ich habe das M-Mona-B kodiert.
M-Mona, Mono-Turink.
Mono.
Morphin, Oxygen, Nitroglycerin.
Aspirin.
Und dann Betablocker.
Ferdinand hat es hier unten gelesen.
In unseren Noten sieht Mono-B-H-Chemik aus.
Aber normalerweise ist Betablocker,
dann, dann ist es schon der letzte,
was Professor Ibrahim sagt,
Betablocker als Sekundärtherapie.
Stathin, Betablocker, Raktograal,
andere A-Z-H-M-A-R-Blocker,
als Sekundärtherapie,
die anderen Situationen der Patient
in Bezug auf die anderen Dinge.
So.
Danke, Ekrem.
Ich habe ein paar Dinge, die ich nennen.
Ich habe eine Unterbrechung gemacht.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich die Gespräche
enden werde.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich stationäre Aufnahmen
machen werde.
Ich sage das nicht so.
Nicht enden, nicht stationäre Aufnahmen.
Ja, ich möchte jetzt das Gespräch unterbrechen.
Und ich werde eine EKG schreiben,
etwas Blut abnehmen,
um ihre Herzfunktion zu beurteilen.
Das ist genug gesagt.
Ich werde eine EKG schreiben, um meine Herzfunktionen zu beurteilen.
Dann werde ich die Kononüge weiterführen.
Wie fühlst du dich jetzt?
Bist du besser?
Geh nicht in diese Dinge.
Die Zeit ist sehr lang.
Du musst es in 18-19 Minuten machen.
Ich möchte das Gespräch kurz beenden.
Ich werde sofort eine EKG schreiben,
Blut abnehmen,
und ich werde die Herzfunktionen beurteilen.
Dann werde ich die Kononüge weiterführen.
Das ist schon klar.
Das ist besser, um keine Zeit zu verlieren.
Wenn du das Gespräch beenden willst,
dann geht es auf eine andere Stelle.
Aber du küsst die Gespräche,
dann wirst du weiter.
Ich gehe nicht in diese Art.
Du machst das in der Schock-Round-Methode.
Du machst die Untabrasion und die Bartoluntabrock.
Dann wirst du die Alpnamen-Gespray beurteilen.
Ja, so können wir das Arbeiten so verstellen.
Wir werden es morgen in der ACS machen.
Wir werden es sehen.
Wenn du Fragen hast,
sage ich das nicht zu dir, aber zu allen.
Es gibt einige Fragen,
die wir uns an die Masse beurteilen müssen.
Oder wir können sie nachher beantworten.
Dann müssen wir eine langen Erklärung machen.
Ich habe die Zeit für die Verlängerung von Paul Breitner gesehen.
Ich habe die Begriffe von ihm gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da was gibt.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Ich hätte es nicht gesehen.
Es gibt nichts, das ausreicht.
Paul Breitner hat es nicht gesehen.
Das ist nicht ein Problem.
Es ist nur ein Problem.
Es ist ein Problem,
dass wir uns in die Begriffe beurteilen.
Es ist sehr bedrohlich.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich mich nicht beurteilen kann.
Aber ich habe gesagt, das ist ein Problem.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es mit dem Begriffe etwas mit sich hat.
Denn wir reden,
aber wir reden und ihr auch.
Es ist ein Problem.
Du hast wohl die Stimme zu spüren.
Oder es gibt ein Problem.
Ich habe das gehört.
Es kann etwas passieren.
Die Vodafone hat heute schon ein bisschen Vartung.
Es gibt zwischen 1 und 3 ein Problem.
Jetzt ist es gut, aber es war schon zu Beginn, aber es ist jetzt zu Ende.
Jetzt vergesst du nicht, die Ausrüstung zu vermitteln.
Wir vermitteln sofort, aber ohne zu warten.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Ausrüstung, Verkauf, Ausrüstung,
z.B. Linkenarm, das ist auch Hals.
So, etwas warten und danach vermitteln.
Dann, wenn du Ausrüstung fragst, vermitteln wir eine Ausrüstung.
Haben Sie eine Bestimmte Ausrüstung für die Schmerzen?
Z.B. Haben Sie sich am Brust verletzt?
Und auch Pneumotorakt ausgedichtet?
Das passiert auch.
Oder was kann man sagen?
Haben Sie eine Bestimmte Ausrüstung für die Schmerzen?
Z.B. haben Sie vor der Aufregung eine Streit oder eine Stresssituation erlebt?
Das ist ein Beispiel.
Verkundet das ein.
Gebe euch ein paar Ausrüstungen.
Z.B. der Fertig-Tark-Faktor oder der Lindert-Faktor.
Wir müssen auch diese ausrechnen.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen ferschtart?
Zum Beispiel Bewegung.
Einige.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen Lindert?
Zum Beispiel Medikament-Ainnahme.
Wenn Sie so sind, werden Sie immer weniger Fragen von den Patienten.
Ich versuche, diese zu beantworten.
Das ist ein Beispiel.
Das ist auch ein Beispiel für diese Schmerzen.
Das bedeutet, dass sie Zeit haben.
Z.B. Akut-Koronars-Syndrom.
Wir warten auf die aktive Runden des Systemes.
Das kann also sein, dass es Kalt-Schweiz, Schwindel, Herzrasen,
Müdigkeit, Angst gibt.
Ich habe diese nicht von den Patienten ausfragen.
Das ist eine Symptom-Küme.
Deswegen habe ich sie so gefragt.
Das ist ein Beispiel.
Das ist Kalt-Schweiz, Schwindel, Schmerzen.
Ich habe das nicht von den Patienten ausfragt.
Das ist ein Beispiel.
Das ist eine Symptom-Küme.
Ich werde die Fragen sagen, wie ich sie beantworten werde.
Vielleicht bleibt mir nicht mehr Zeit.
Dann hören wir Ipek ab.
Dann wird İbrahim bei uns sein.
Wenn ihr eine kardiologische Frage habt,
dann fragt sie.
Als ich den Akut-Koronars-Syndrom-Wakas gemacht habe,
hatte ich die Begegnung,
dass ich auf Schmerzen komme.
Ich sage es euch alle,
dass Schmerzen nicht wichtig ist.
Ich schaue die gleiche Art.
Wo ist Schmerzen?
Ich schreibe eine EKG.
Ich nehme etwas Blut ab,
um die Funktionen zu beherrschen.
Ich schreibe eine EKG.
Dann schreibe ich die Schmerzen.
Das war's.
Ich habe nichts zu dem Patient zu sagen.
Ich habe das gesagt.
Dann ...
Der Patient hat sehr viel zu sagen.
Vielleicht hat er zuerst einiges zu sagen.
Ich frage ihn nicht,
ich frage ihn nicht.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Das ist die Begegnung, die ich gehört habe.
Wenn du einen Patient zu sagen hast,
dann kannst du ihn hier sofort fragen.
Bevor du die Situation mit Schmerzen
bezeichnen kannst,
dann kannst du Lufnot,
Herzrasen, Engelgöphül,
diese Frage fragen.
Dann kannst du den Schmerz weiterführen.
Also ...
Wenn du noch Schmerzen hast,
dann kannst du ihnen weiterführen.
Bevor du Schmerzen siehst,
dann kannst du euch die Schmerzen
bezeichnen.
Dann kannst du Schmerz fragen,
und dann ...
Dann kannst du es fragen,
dass du das erste Mal Schmerz hast.
Dann kannst du das Bir.-Dert-Faktor fragen.
Aber ich glaube, dass man das nicht so oft in der Brusssimmerse fragen muss.
Wenn man dann die Symptomatischen, Sympathischen, Aktivierung,
die Symptome fragt, stellt man eine Frage.
Und dann fragt man sich, was man für eine Differenzialdiagnose denkt.
Was denkt man über das Gasreusophagel-Reflu-Krankheit-Pulmener-Rang?
Ein paar Fragen.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich das nicht erinnere.
Das ist das, was ich gesagt habe.
Jetzt frage ich das Gasreusophagel-System.
Die Erdbeeren, Stuhlgang-Probleme oder Baselasen-Probleme.
Die Erdbeeren habe ich hier hergebracht.
Und das war das Gettet von Amnese.
Dann kommen wir zum klassischen.
Die wichtigste Reaktion hier ist, das zu kassieren.
Das haben wir schon gesprochen.
Die anderen Reaktionen, die es gibt, sind die Todesangst.
Das ist die Erdbeeren-Probleme.
Die Erdbeeren sind die Todesangst.
Aber sie sind nicht in der Krankenhaus.
Sie sind nicht in der guten Hand.
Sie sind unsere Bestes-Physi.
Das ist die Erdbeeren-Probleme.
Sie sind in der Krankenhaus.
Sie sind in der besten Hand.
Ich habe leider auch nicht ihre Schwester untersucht.
Ich empfehle ihr, dass sie einen Hausarzt besucht, um eine gute Behandlung zu bekommen.
Sie können so etwas sagen.
Sie können auch etwas mit der Tätigkeit sagen.
Aber es ist wichtig, dass sie etwas mit der Tätigkeit sagen.
Auch wenn es kurz ist.
Sie können etwas mit der Tätigkeit sagen.
Es ist wichtig, etwas kurz zu sagen.
Nein, die Arztinnen können nicht verantwortlich sein.
Sie können zum Hausarzt oder Hauptarzt besuchen.
Und warum Statin im Abend umgebracht wird, fragt der Arzt.
Die Arztinnen hier kennen die Kardiokontrollen besser.
Aber die Statin-Gruppe ist besser, weil die Cholester-Aktivitäten im Körper sind.
Ich habe mich hier angetan.
Du hast gesagt, dass die Jury nicht gefällt.
Du hast gesagt, dass wir nicht darüber reden.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Du hast gesagt, dass du dich nicht mehr konzentrieren kannst.
Muss man das im Bedingungen machen?
Ich habe die Arztinne immer wieder verantwortlich gesagt.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass sie etwas mit der Tätigkeit sagen können.
Ich habe sie gesagt, dass ich sie nicht mehr mit der Tätigkeit sagen kann.
Aber ich habe sie fast nie benutzt.
Das ist sehr zwingend.
Die Arztinnen sagen etwas, aber sie sind nicht gefällt.
Aber sie sagen etwas, dann das, dann das.
Das hat nichts mit der Situation zu tun.
Ich kann die Arztinne nicht mehr beantworten.
Aber ich kann sie nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Dann kann ich sie nicht mehr beantworten.
Das kann man sagen.
Okay, ich werde das machen.
Danke.
Das ist die Meinung meiner Kollegen.
Sie können mir etwas kümmern.
Ich versuche, die Noten zu beachten.
Die Zeit ist wichtig.
Danke.
Ich glaube, das ist die Meinung meiner Kollegen.
Sie können sich einander bewegen, aber sie können sich die letzte Waffe bewegen.
Florent kann dich nicht mehr bewegen.
Sie können sich nicht mehr bewegen.
Dann können wir sie nicht mehr bewegen.
Danke.
Sie haben ein paar Fragen.
Sie haben eine Antwort, aber sie lassen sich noch von Ihnen aus.
Sie können es dann sagen.
Danke.
Okay, dann ist die Frau Ipek.
Guten Tag.
Sie haben eine kurze Zeit.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne vorstellen.
Ich möchte Sie natürlich beweisen.
Es geht um Philip Kaya.
Er ist 59 Jahre alt.
Geboren am 01.11.1965.
Er ist 1 Meter 90 groß und 90 kg schwer.
Er kam heute zu uns.
plötzlich aufgetretene Postprandial-Toraxschmützen mit und ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Schmerzkarakteren seien dümpfend und drückend.
Am Anfang starrte diese Schmerz in Tenth-State, bei 6 von 10.
Aber jetzt liegt 3 bis 4 von 10.
Erschöpft und Todesangst.
An vegetative Anamnese erwähnt er Schmerzbedingte in Appetens und Übelkeit ohne Erbrechen.
Im Rahmen der Vorerkrankungen hat der Patient seit 5 Jahren Blut-Arterie-Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er 1 Morgens Ramipril und 5 mg.
Darüber hinaus leidet er an Hyperlipidemie seit 10 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt er 40 mg abends ein.
Er berichtet auch kranische Husten seit mindestens 20 Jahren.
An der Operation ist es auch unrelevant.
Als Allergien bekannt ist Erdnuss-Allergie.
Er wird aus Atemnot und Schwellung ermutigt.
An der Operation sind seit 30 Jahren drei Zigaretten und Alkoholkonsum.
Die Alkoholkonsum ist ein Glas Wein, das Drogenkonsum für den Fernaid.
Im Rahmen der Vorerkrankungen hat der Patient seit 10 Jahren Blut-Arterie-Hypertonie.
Familienanamnistisch leidet der Vater an Herzanfall.
Leider ist er vor 2 Jahren verstorben.
Er leidet an Herzanfall.
Das bedeutet momentan hat er einen Herzanfall.
Er liegt vielleicht an.
Die Mutter ist vor 3 Jahren an Schlaganfall gestorben.
Der Vater ist vor 3 Jahren an Schlaganfall gestorben.
Wie Herr Kaya, der Bruder leidet an Arterie-Hypertonie.
Er ist...
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf...
Aufgrund der Anamnese-Gespräche habe ich einen Verdacht auf...
akutes Coronäuresyndrom,
eine Differentialdiagnose,
eine Gaseosefagielleflüge und eine Autodesektion in Betracht.
Zu weiterer Abklärung würde ich gerne körperliche Untersuchungen,
intensiv stationär aufnehmen,
natürlich Monitorisation weiterführen und nach dem Blutergebnis
nicht nach dem Blutergebnis Blut abnehmen.
Deswegen habe ich auch derzeit
eine Kardiologische Konzertantwortung.
Wie ich...
Okay.
Als Apartheit und Diagnose würde ich gerne...
Icheinzige Abklärung.
Hier ist es noch besser, das zu sagen.
Ja.
Zuerst sag mal was du tust.
Und dann sag mal was du tust.
Während des Anamnese-Gesprächs habe ich schon einen EKG geschrieben,
die Vitalparameter überprüft und Blut etwas abgenommen.
Jetzt werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen machen,
danach wieder einen EKG schreiben
und als Apartheit werde ich eine Eko-Kardiographie veranlassen
und ich werde auf eine Konzertantwortung für Kardiologen,
um die veranlässt.
Ich sage zuerst was ich tue, was ich jetzt tue.
Kannst du das sagen?
Ja.
Dann wird es veranlässt.
Du hast es gesagt,
dann hast du den Patienten in die Intensivstationen
und in die Therapie gearbeitet.
Es ist etwas in meinem Kopf.
Kannst du das sagen?
Was ist Monitoring?
Der Patient wird monitoriert.
Aber in diesem Bereich ist es nicht stationär aufgenommen.
Er ist noch mal aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patienten stationär aufgenommen.
Intensiv stationär aufgenommen.
Und jetzt ist der Rest der Kardiologie.
Ich habe mich jetzt in den Kopf gerissen.
Was du sagen würdest,
dann würde ich ihn beantragen.
Oder der Patient wird eine Eko-Kardiographie durchgeführt.
Wo das ist, werde ich die Notauffnangudien machen.
Und genau zum theepe.
Dieser Patient sı anxious be lovely.
Wenn der Patient die Intensivstationen aufgenommen hat,
dann folgt der Patient die Mono-BHCMA,
ich folge Mono-BHCMA,
ich gebe Morphin und dann Sauerstoffgabe.
Wenn der Patient niedrig ist,
dann erklärt man das, was man selbst gemacht hat.
Dann sagt man, dass man eine Percutane-Coronare-Intervention hat.
Das ist der Bypass, das ist der letzte Satz.
Das sagt man am Ende.
Der Kardiologen sieht das.
Wenn der Patient niedrig ist,
dann folgt der Patient die Mono-BHCMA,
das ist der letzte Satz.
Dann erklärt man, dass man eine Percutane-Coronare-Intervention oder ein Coronare-Bypass hat.
Wenn der Patient niedrig ist,
dann erklärt man das, was man selbst gemacht hat.
dann erklärt man, dass man eine Percutane-Coronare-Intervention oder ein Coronare-Bypass hat.
Wenn der Patient niedrig ist,
dann erklärt man das, was man selbst gemacht hat.
wie Blutzucker, Herzentzimen, Leber- und Nierenwerteparameter und Gerindierungsparameter,
auch akkumuliert. Jetzt würde ich gerne kardiologisches Konsul durchführen,
wenn meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen würde ich gerne,
dass ich das nicht für den Test mache.
Hallo Freunde, die neue Gruppe 12 wird beginnen.
Ich möchte nicht zu lange sprechen, ich sage es so,
jeder Kliniker muss akkutkoronär-Syndrom wissen, wer das ist.
Das ist die generelle Regelung der Welt, nicht nur für den Test.
Ich möchte nicht sagen, dass es ein anderes Thema ist,
aber es ist gut, ein paar Sätze zu sagen.
Wenn es nicht um Kardiologische Konsul ist,
dann ist es nicht so wichtig, dass man die Versammlung nicht so oft fragt.
Nur als Name zu sagen ist genug.
Ich glaube, es ist genug.
Aber es ist in den Noten geschrieben, es ist ein ganzes Buch,
es ist ein Verlust, als würde ich als Kardiologiker fragen.
Ich weiß nicht, es kann gelesen werden.
Haben Sie noch weitere Fragen?
Wir haben noch nicht alle Fragen.
Wir gehen.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Ich habe Akkutkoronär-Syndrom. Bis bald.
Danke.